هنا ثانيه ليس اكثر وقعها مدمر
وارتداداتها اكثر تدميرا ولا تزال متواصله
تلك هي مده زلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا
وغير حياه اكثر من ثلاثه وعشرين مليون شخص
زلزال بقوه السبعه فاصل تسعه درجه ضرب في
السادس من فبراير على عمق نحو 17 كيلومترا
قرب مدينه غازي عنتاب جنوبي تركيا اي على
عمق عشره كيلومترات فقط قرب مدينه كهرمان
مرعش وكانت الساعه حينها الواحده وسبعه
عشره دقيقه بتوقيت جرينتش ووفق شهود
الزلزال استمر دقيقه واحده وصفت بدقيقه
الموت مدمرا المباني في المناطق المذكوره
ونوافذ منازل في مدن تبعد نحو 350
كيلومترا شرقا مثل ديار بكر
الزلزال في سوريا لم يكن اخف بل اركع
مباني متهالكه تحاول جاهده التماسك بعد
حرب استمرت 12 عاما لتتجدد صور الحطام
وانتشال الجثث والمصابين والذين قدروا
بالالاف
بعد 11 دقيقه من الزلزال الاول تعرضت
المنطقه لهزه ارتداديه بلغت قوتها 6.7
درجه لتبدا الكارثه حيث لم تنتهي سابقتها
زلزال اخر اعقبها بقوه 7.5 درجه تالته هزه
اخرى بقوه 6 درجات في فتره ما بعد الظهر
مع توقعات بامتداد النشاط الزلزلي الى
فجوه مجاوره
متى ما تيسر والانصات لهمهمه عالقين تحت
الانقاض تغص المشافي بالمصابين الذين
ملئوا الممرات دون قدره على علاجهم فيما
اخرون نفذوا من براثن الزلزال لتتكسر على
اجسادهم عاصفه ليست اقل رحمه